Rheneas for lunch sir oh no I've already
consumed the required calories for this
day period yummy but I do have some fun
lunch chitchat when I was a detective my
old co Jim Martin's used to keep us on
our toes by having us solve brain
teasers I thought maybe you'd like to
try one
don't just tease my brain captain really
go to town on it yeah bring it on sir I
love puzzles
they're like power squats for your mind
good here's the problem there are 12 men
on an island 11 way exactly the same
amount but one of them is slightly
lighter or heavier you must figure out
which and what do these men look like
facially and with respect to their
bodies it's unimportant
so like Tyrese it's Orlando Tyrese's
truth the island has no scales but there
is a seesaw the exciting catch you can
only use it three times that sounds
super exciting is this thing mandatory
oh I hope so please say yes no but there
is a prize for whoever solves it first
two tickets to the sundaes Beyonce
Knowles
rock music concert I'm in Marcos loves
me on say everyone was Beyonce my girls
were conceived to bootylicious don't
tell my wife I told you that no offense
but this is gonna come down to me and
Sarge whoa you think you two are the
only ones could solve puzzles yeah what
about Rosa Gina and me is this how you
want to die Hitchcock look it's just
that the Sarge and I are really into
puzzles remember when I took that Sudoku
cruise I never even went on deck 100
bucks says Gina and I can solve this
thing before you two puzzle dorks deal
you're going down I'm really not a part
of this Hitchcock there is no way we let
Amy in the surge beat us we sit here
until we figure this thing out well in
my mind it's ready okay there's an
island with 12 men oh I cannot do it I
can do this one guy's slightly heavier
there's a seesaw I got it
you use the seesaw to press down on
their necks until fatty confesses
correct damn and disturbing stop the
clock we're here and we have the
solution
first you waste six versus six wrong
that'll never work you just wasted your
time and mine click I just captured the
exact moment when you realize you had
failed I guess we all got something out
of this so that's it this problem is
beyond all of you
no one solved it believe me no one is
more disappointed in me than me than I
said oh wait captain Jean and I figured
out your dumb brain teaser I highly
doubt that sir I'll judge for myself
Santiago
okay Diaz what's the solution we have no
idea soldier but neither do you sir what
captain Holt you don't know what the
solution is excuse me here's how we
cracked it I took the photo of you
demolishing amy's spirit and made these
clever t-shirts that say hashtag nerd
fail it's not that clever it's hilarious
look at this your expression is the same
as Amy's because you're both devastated
that you just let down your mentors I
looked at your calendar you're supposed
to have breakfast with your old CEO he
wanted us to solve the problem before
you saw him that's crazy
she's right what No he posed that
problem to me 20 years ago every time I
see him he asked do you have the answer
yet and I never have those Islanders and
they're pathetic seesaw haunt my dreams
they mock me in my sleep riding up and
down on a teeter-totter of taunts cool
so who gets the beyoncé tickets where is
everyone Gina
perhaps that's tonight's first puzzle I
forgot to send the invitations but I was
able to rally the best and brightest of
those available oh dear God sorry we're
late
turns out the front door is a push not a
pull oh maybe we should just reschedule
I have three hours to find the four keys
that will prevent the apocalypse and
release you from this room your time
starts now
well this is a sobering reality this
says we have three questions no oh how
do we get out of here
really that's enough sorry about that
can we please have my questions back No
Oh captain
how could you so if I'm correct this
should contain key number one yay open
the door no we need to find four keys
and it took half our time just to find
this one because I had to do it
completely alone you're all useless
sorry I've been a little busy trying to
solve the puzzle of how does one man
chew so loud with just one mouth sorry
could you stop kicking her things for
one minute Hitchcock the TVs being a
dick you gotta turn it like four times
just to change the Damn Channel four
times try turning it to 22 1881
seventeen the coordinates for the Bay of
Pigs
nice job you broke the TV no I found
another key you dolt
so one was in a knight the basketball
teams were the Mustangs and stallions we
only need two more keys
this just might work out after all
you're damn right it will cuz we're a
ragtag scrap 'ti fart dumb [ __ ] parade
smart ass team what in this room is
speaking to you right now I'm intrigued
by the phone it looks like it would be
fun to call a friend on it and talk
about a third friend behind their back
interesting the dial tone stops Teddy I
think it's most cold I know Morse code
my dad was a prisoner of war in Korea
and I could only talk to him who cares
just decode the message
it's a phone number ready
[Music]
congratulations we did it and we did it
together because we're a team should we
do it again next week sir no I would
hate that
yeah Santiago settle a little tiff the
Kevin and I are having let's be honest
Raymond it's not at if it's a row and
now it's a scene that's okay sir we
don't wanna get involved in your
personal life it's not personal it's a
math problem Raymond and I had dinner
together last night for the first time
in two weeks thanks to the night shift
thank heaven thought it would be fun to
spoil our date with an inane math
problem to which his answer is wrong
enough foreplay let's get to the numbers
it's the Monty Hall problem imagine
you're on a game show there are three
doors behind one of which is a car
you're telling it wrong there are three
doors behind one of which is a car you
pick a door the host who knows where the
car is opens a different door showing
you there's nothing behind it now the
host asks if you'd like to choose the
other unopened door should you do it no
yes
it's simple math it doesn't make any
sense to switch the prize is behind one
of two doors it's a 50/50 chance either
way it's 2/3 of you switch 1/3 if you
don't the probability locks in when you
make the choice we've been over this
eight times seven times now you can't
even do simple additional Kevin is right
you're fired
what good evening sir no it's not I
haven't slept because I've been going
over that stupid problem now I finally
understand Kevin's side cool so it's all
better and I never have to hear about
math again quite the opposite I know
better than ever how incorrect he is
probability doesn't kick in throughout
to teach you college-level statistics I
don't know do I have to teach you high
school statistics throughout the teach
you eighth grade statistic do I have to
teach you
seventh grade statistic do I have to
teach you now if you'll excuse me
detectives I need to leave him a slice
mail about kindergarten statistics okay
we have got to explain this thing to
captain Holt to save their relationship
and you laughed at me when I went to
that weekend long math conference
because you called it funky cats and
they're feisty steps that was the name
it was so cool it was not anyway it's
not about the math they haven't seen
each other because of the night shift I
just need a bone what gross Rosa
those are our dads I mean that's not
what I think captain dad is just my boss
Wow never mind I'm teaching father the
math
he's everything okay no I lost my ring
do you see where we're actually it's
behind one of these three doors
why don't you pick one are you trying to
Monty Hall me it's unbelievable
I don't need Monty Hall ruining my place
of work with Monty Hall has already
ruined my home life come on sir the math
thing isn't the problem night shifts
keeping you and Kevin apart
you two just need a bone
I said you two need a bone Oh dare you
detective Diaz I am your superior
officer Oh what happens in my bedroom
detective is none of your business don't
ever speak to me like that again
[Music]
why'd she choose that dude his pen up
now he knows problem solved
Oh captain I know you don't want to talk
about Monty Hall but I did contact a man
no need Santiago it's all good sir fight
with Kevin is over yep because you
understand the map nope hey guys you
guys yep knew it
hmm see what happen is she doesn't sick
you